Speaker 1: All of this covid misinformation
is coming on the heels of several governors
who are banning measures to mitigate the spread
of infection, hospitalization and death.
Abbott in Texas, the Santos in Florida, all
these areas across the country that are led
by ridiculous charlatan clowns in the governor's
offices.
And it is good news to hear that several local
organizational efforts are being made in municipalities
across those states to counteract to defy
the order of banning mass mandates.
Reading from the Hill Florida school board
votes to keep mask mandate defying DeSantis,
the Broward County School Board on Tuesday
voted eight to one to retain its massive mandate
for students and staff members, defying Florida
Gov..
Rhonda Santos's executive order forcing school
districts to make masks optional.
The Fort Lauderdale School Board is seeking
legal counsel to challenge the executive order,
which it claims represents government overreach.
According to, quote, wearing masks inside
schools, regardless of vaccine status, is
required to deal with the changing realities
of virus transmission.
It is a necessary precaution until children
under 12 can receive a covid-19 vaccination
and more Americans 12 and older get vaccinated,
which came from Anna Fusako, president of
the Broward Teachers Union.
It's not just Florida, though.
In Texas, again, there are measures in place
to defy the governors and die health mandates.
KSAT, the San Antonio affiliate judge, delivers
a blow to Texas Gov..
Abbott's ban on mandates allows San Antonio
to require masks and schools.
Temporary restraining order allow San Antonio
Bexar County to impose mass mandates.
San Antonio leaders scored a victory in court
against Texas Gov. Greg Abbott on Tuesday
in the ongoing fight over mask mandates in
Bexar County, Civil District Court judge granted
the city of Bexar County his request for a
temporary restraining order against Abbott's
executive order banning mask mandates in school.
Again, other than fueling the culture war.
What is the impetus here?
What is the goal?
What is the objective in banning in creating
a system where local municipalities listen?
Republicans always say this.
Local authorities know better than the federal
government.
They know what's best for them.
Well, why is that not the case for a local
city to impose a mass mandate for their community,
their local community, who is is Greg Abbott,
the governor of Texas?
Who is he to know more about what's best for
that local community using Republican logic?
Then the community itself.
Instead, they are prohibiting local municipalities
to create more stringent rules surrounding
protecting the health and welfare of their
residents effectively, the ruling allows Bexar
County and San Antonio officials to issue
a massive mandate in public schools and other
guidance, like quarantine protocol for now.
Officials say they plan to have an order issued
by the end of Tuesday.
No details have been released yet on the guidance,
but officials will hold a live press conference
at six 10 p.m..
The order was granted after an hour long hearing
by the 57 Civil District Court with Judge
Tony Ortega, Ortega said an affidavit from
MetroHealth chief medical officer Dr Jundah,
who weighed heavily in her decision, as did
the vulnerability of children who were returning
to school amid a surge in coronavirus cases.
That sentence bears repeating.
Weighed heavily on her decision was the vulnerability
of children who are returning to school amid
a surge in coronavirus cases.
And this is what is perplexing.
It is baffling to me because although Republican,
they're still human beings, ostensibly they
possess some level of empathy, less they they
suffer from sociopathy.
Why don't they care about the surging cases
of coronavirus all across their states?
This is from Louisiana, reading from The Insider
in New Orleans Children's Hospital, doctor
says reopening schools without masks is a
formula for disaster as covid-19 rages in
Louisiana.
This isn't just salacious use of words in
these headlines.
The pandemic is raging a year and a half in,
it is raging in these areas, Louisiana has
finally seen an uptick in vaccinations in
the vaccination rates of of its citizens because
of the fact that people look around and they
know they have family members who are doggin.
They have family members, maybe multiple,
who are hospitalized.
They're witnessing children now get sick.
Reopening schools loaded with unvaccinated
children and no mask requirements in place
is a formula for disaster.
The physician in chief of the Children's Hospital
in New Orleans said, I think bringing together
large numbers of children, congregating them
in classrooms with masks being optional or
worse yet even forbidden, is just a formula
for disaster.
Dr. Mark Klein said in an interview with CNN
it couldn't be more plainly stated.
Republicans have turned the culture war, the
war on Christmas and what color coffee cup
Starbucks has these nonsense arguments.
They have turned it into something that is
deadly.
It's one thing if you want to whine about
the national anthem and someone silently kneeling
in protest and you want to turn that into
a culture war, it's another thing entirely
when you endanger the lives of children.
Innocent babies.
Who are have no other choice but to be protected.
They cannot do it themselves.
We're not horses or goats or cows that get
squirted out and immediately are on our feet
walking around eating grass.
That's not how it works with human beings.
I'm sad to say Republicans.
We need nurturing and protection for a great
deal of time before we're capable of doing
it ourselves.
And Greg Abbott and Rhonda Santurce are getting
in the way of that.
They're making a choice.
To force municipalities into a situation where
they're either violating the law.
We're making sure their kids are safe.
Unconscionable.